voici maintenant le portrait d'un
sportif plutôt atypique on est loin
justement des footballeurs qui se
vendent au plus offrant et pourtant
nikola karabatic est un authentique
champion de handball peut-être le
meilleur joueur du monde
ces quatre dernières années s'était
exilé en allemagne le pays du handball
il était bien payé
eh bien écoutez il a décidé de revenir
en france à montpellier pour retrouver
toute sa famille c'est parfois mieux
qu'un gros chèque
julien benedetto et mickaël cariou vous
n'y connaissez rien au handball mesdames
voici l'homme qui va muscler vos
connaissances en la matière nikola
karabatic cultive son look de
gladiateurs glamour
l'athlète lens entre deux entraînements
sa ligne de sous vêtements mode mais
aussi produits de beauté de nombreuses
marques s'arrachent son image derrière
le business une mission promouvoir le
handball toujours voulu qu'ils aient
plus de rater dès que les gens s'y
intéressent plus que les gens
connaissent que ses joueurs mais ces
voix-là de de montrer au peuple français
que ça super sport à 25 ans
karabatic et son bras d'acier ont déjà
tout gagné championnat d'europe
championnat du monde et médaille d'or
olympique avec les bleus un talent à
priori hors de prix pour un club
français
mais après quatre saisons en allemagne
ils acceptent de diminuer son salaire et
signe à montpellier son club formateur
c'est comme si ribéry revenait en ligue
1 premier match de la saison karabatic à
la baguette
creteil encaisse 47 buts
on remet ça avec impatience le drone
harfang devant cette salle trop stérile
ce public c'est maintenant à coeur le
meilleur joueur du monde aurait pu
gagner deux fois plus d'argent à
barcelone mais il a choisi de rejoindre
sa famille à montpellier né en serbie
nicolas est arrivé en france à l'âge de
trois ans il entretient une relation
quasi fusionnelle avec son père branko
ancien gardien de but de l'ex
yougoslavie peine à retenir ses larmes
quand il évoque le départ de son fils en
allemagne il ya quatre ans effectivement
même aujourd'hui encore qu'on parle de
ça c'est c'est vrai c'était pas c'était
pas facile de le laisser partir
non c'était le prix quelque part arrivé
maintenant le colosse au grand coeur
puis sa force auprès des siens dans ses
repas de famille qu'il n'échangerait pas
pour tout l'or du monde